and the spirit award for best male
performance in a new scripted series
goes to
amit rahav for unorthodox
oh my god oh my god
um thank you so so much
i'm so excited thank you everyone at
film independent spirit awards for this
amazing honor thank you so so much um
thank you netflix thank you deborah
feldman for sharing your memoir
um with the world thank you anna and
alexa for adapting
uh this memoir into this marvelous show
that i'm so proud to be a part of thank
you maria my dearest director
shira my my love my ex-wife my wife i
love you
ellie henning jeff my man i love you um
thank you so much to my managers scott
justin zach hadassi ron
yoni um itai i love you
um thank you so much estelle kling iran
thank you and i want to dedicate this
award to my family my sisters
and especially to my mom who's here
videoing me um
she always forced me to thank her
whenever we saw
all of the award shows when i was young
and uh this is the moment so this is
dedicated to you
thank you so so much i'm so happy
you